[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
créer voici deux mois à Addis-Abeba
l'Organisation de l'Unité Africaine a
tenu sa première conférence à Dakar
[Musique]
le président de la République
sénégalaise a rappelé que dans sa grande
majorité l'Organisation de l'Unité
Africaine est composée d'État modérés
soucieux d'efficacité
[Musique]
la grève des marins est aujourd'hui
heureusement terminée c'en est fini pour
les Marseillais de voir le port encombré
de navires attendant un départ incertain
mais pendant des jours on a pu voir sur
les quais sur le pont des navires les
passagers embarqués pour la Corse et
pour l'Afrique du Nord obligé de
s'organiser pour vivre en attendant que
la greffe s'arrête en présence de ces
difficultés le gouvernement a dû prendre
des mesures importantes pour mettre fin
à la situation précaire de ces milliers
de personnes il a donc dans ce sens fait
assurer les liaisons par la Marine
nationale et l'on a pu voir à Toulon les
matelots du croiseur de Grasse et dire à
l'embarquement des passagers qui
n'avaient jamais pensé être conduit à
bon au port sous la volée des canons
mesure de circonstances qui aura permis
d'abréger l'attente et d'en finir avec
les heures pénibles des passagers en
souffrance il ne restera pour ses
passagers du de grâce que le souvenir de
journée perdu souvenir qui s'estompera
au cours des vacances en ce qui concerne
le fond du problème lui-même la sagesse
du personnel des compagnies a aidé
sûrement à sa solution raisonnable et
durable
[Musique]
c'est bien les vacances même pour
l'expert personnage divin qui était
naguer l'empereur du Japon aujourd'hui
redevenu un très simple humain en
rupture de travail quotidien de la villa
au bord de la mer qu'il habite pendant
les vacances il s'en va chaque jour avec
l'impératrice à la recherche de
spécimens nouveau de coquillages qu'il
destinent à ses travaux de laboratoire
on s'est en effet que l'empereur héroïto
est connu dans le monde scientifique
comme biologiste sans contrainte et en
famille tout pareil à un bon bourgeois
féru de sciences voilà l'empereur et
l'impératrice du Japon en vacances
[Musique]
vacances studieuse à l'ombre de
l'amphithéâtre romain de Nîmes
l'archéologie depuis quelques années est
à la mode et elle est même devenue une
distraction de choix pour les loisirs de
certains lycéens dans ce pays provençal
où les vestiges gagnent le Romain
surgissent partout il reste bien des
choses à découvrir la province est
encore pour longtemps un lieu de
fouilles intéressantes et nos jeunes
gens jouent avec beaucoup de conviction
à l'archéologue
précautionneux se conformant aux
méthodes de recherche éprouvées il passe
leur journée à la recherche d'un monde
disparu et chaque découverte est pour
une récompense
déjà la petite collection de trouvailles
s'accroît dans des proportions notables
elle constituera le premier fond du
futur musée de nageses dont il prospecte
l'oppidum et qui a déjà son conservateur
il va de soi que cette idée de musée
tourmente maintenant toutes les
cervelles et il n'est dans la région si
jeune vacances et qui ne pense déjà avec
délectation à sa collection particulière
mis en service en 1821 le vieux pont de
Bordeaux entre les deux rives de la
Garonne près de son estuaire et devenue
avec la circulation moderne un lourd
souci sur le grand axe routier du Sud le
flot des voitures extrêmement abondance
il resserre obligatoirement
occasionnant bouchon et retard
Bordeaux construit donc un nouveau pont
suspendu à l'image de celui de
Tancarville auquel on accédera sur la
rive gauche par un viaduc d'accès dont
la longueur 871 mètres et double de
celui de Tancarville ces pilons de
porteurs dont les ancrages sont en cours
d'exécution s'élèveront jusqu'à 104
mètres contre 123 pour le pont normand
et le tablier surplombra de 53 m les
eaux de la Garonne laissant ainsi la
route libre au plus gros navire ce sera
l'un des plus beaux ouvrages du genre
construire est un devoir conserver en
états
Richelieu au confins du Poitou et de
l'Anjou reste aujourd'hui tels que le
construisit Armand du Plessis cardinal
de Richelieu Premier ministre de Louis
XII et grand homme d'État du château
celle qu'il avait voulu magnifique rien
ne subsiste qu'un pavillon déconne le
reste a été dépecé est vendu pierre par
pierre au début du 19e siècle mais
excellente exemple d'urbanisme classique
la petite ville demeure debout
aujourd'hui classée en entier monument
historique et sa grande rue un peu trop
défigurée hélas par les vitrines qui se
sont élargies aux dépens des
architectures garde toujours sa grande
allure
le plan de restauration de Richelieu est
un effet en cours de réalisation et les
coins maltraités par les siècles ou par
les hommes se retrouveront dans quelques
années arraché à la vétusté et à la
ruine telles les halles avec leur
magnifique charpente véritable
chef-d'oeuvre d'assemblage remise en
étalant dernier Richelieu que la
fontaine appelait le plus beau village
de l'univers petit coin du patrimoine
national hier oublié est en voie de
renaissance
[Musique]
Notre-Dame démaquillée c'est une autre
œuvre de conservation et de
rajeunissement à laquelle on vient de se
livrer sur le portail central de
Notre-Dame de Paris dont on célébrait
voici de moi le 8e centenaire on pouvait
craindre les méfaits d'un ravalement
mais avec la méthode employée le
résultat est très encourageant
les siècles sans doute n'est surtout les
poussières et les fumées de notre temps
avaient accumulé une crasse épaisse
parfois de 3 cm
aujourd'hui le portail central retrouve
un relief imprévu et la suite des
vierges folles au milieu des démons
grimaçants qu'on revoit d'aujourd'hui
dans leur puissance d'expression
primitive nous ramène d'un seul coup le
goût vigoureux de ce Moyen-Âge qui
souhaitait à la fois énorme et délicat
[Musique]
pour les routiers professionnels qui
participent au Championnats du monde de
cyclisme à Renaix en Belgique c'est leur
h le favori numéro 1 l'homme abattre
c'est Rick vanlogue
le voilà Rick van live avec son dossard
numéro 11
le début de la course sous la pluie se
déroule tambour battant avec plusieurs
tentatives d'échapper parmi ces échappés
celle de Henri Anglade du Hollande et
dehane et d'andrégade elle est vouée à
l'échec comme toutes les autres van
Lloyd veille au grain il Colma toutes
les brèches avec beaucoup de brio pas de
doute 20 live va gagner c'était prévu
mais attention regardez bien il y a une
faille dans le scénario le Belge bait ne
joue pas le jeu il bat le super champion
malgré les ordres reçus après un sprint
de tumultueux il aurait peut-être mieux
valu pour batte qu'il ne soit pas
champion du monde mais ceci est une
autre histoire
la ville de Leipzig en Allemagne de
l'Est a été cette année le théâtre d'un
grand rassemblement de la jeunesse du
monde entier à l'occasion du 4e Festival
du sport et de la gymnastique
[Applaudissements]
120 000 personnes ont assisté à cette
parade monstre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des heures durant athlètent et gymnastes
ont présenté les exercices chaudement
applaudis par les spectateurs
enthousiastes
[Musique]
plus de 20000 jeunes gens et jeunes
filles ont participé au final de cette
grande fête de la jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est sans doute parmi eux que l'on
découvrira les grands champions de
demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]